so our first speaker gave a TED talk at
tEDGlobal I think seven years ago his
name is Professor URI Allen at the
Weizmann Institute of Science now he and
his colleagues there have come up with a
powerful idea that addresses this key
question how on earth do we get back to
work without creating a second surge of
the infection Marie Allen welcome to Ted
thank you nice to be here
you can again so I guess the key to your
idea is this obsession with the
reproduction number RR not if that
number is less than 1 then fewer than
one person is in that is infected by a
typical person and eventually the
epidemic fades away people are worried
that as we come back to work our will
shoot up above one again you have a
suggestion on how we might avoid that
what is what is that suggestion exactly
so we are suggesting a strategy that's
based on a weak spot based on the
biology of the virus which is a cycle of
work and lockdown it exploits the
vulnerability of the virus and then when
a person gets infected their noxious for
about three days so you know you don't
expect others for it first three days
and after another two days on average
you get symptoms and that so we're
proposing a strategy which is four days
of work and then 10 days of lockdown and
the next two weeks again four days of
work ten days of lockdown and that way
if a person gets infected at work they
reach their peak infectiousness during
lockdown and that way they avoid
infecting many others this restricts the
viral transmission also just working for
days of two weeks restricts the amount
of time the virus gets to see many other
people and that's a very powerful effect
so everybody works on the same for days
kids go to school on the same four days
with all the measures of social
distancing and masks
etc and then there's a lockdown period
so if you take the worst-case scenario
where you come to work on a Monday
morning at the starti or four days and
and you're infected on that on the
subway say on the way to work the theory
here is that even by the end of that
four days you're not really starting to
infect your coworkers that's correct so
you're infected on the subway and so for
the first three days or so you're in
your latent period and you don't infect
your co-workers you reach your peak
infectiousness at home there will be
secondary infections at home and people
with symptoms can self quarantine and
over the long run you have reproduction
number less than 1 so the epidemic if
you continue these cycles will go away
holes I mean is it is it is it
frustrating at the thought that people
are going to say wait I don't want to
infect people at home I'd rather infect
people at work than at home absolutely
so you have to consider the alternatives
if you open up the economy and there's a
second wave you'll get all those
infections anyway during the lockdown
that happens devastating effects on the
economy etc and so in the long run if
you do a cyclic strategy like this with
the production number that's less than
one you you avoid considerations the
much larger number of infections you get
if there's a second way right in the
family by sorry I said even people who
are infected don't infect everyone at
home the attack rates are about ten to
thirty percent according to several
studies right but the hope is that
you're serving that needs of your family
by engaging the strategy where very few
of your fellow workers are going to be
infectious anyway so that's that's the
plan but it's really you know tell me
this though because four days out of 14
someone's going to say well great idea
but that that implies like a 70% loss of
productivity in the in the economy so
that can't possibly work I think you
think that the productivity loss need
not be anything like that much
that's right and force people most
people don't work weekend so it's four
days out of the ten work days in two
weeks
and once you've predictable schedule
four days at work you can work longer
hours you can design shifts and get
higher productivity by prioritizing in
those four days much more than 40% of
the work days yes sir to talk through
how that could work I mean let's imagine
first of all like manufacturing which is
currently shut down is the implication
here that a manufacturer could set up
sort of two possibly even three shifts
of four days maybe thirty five hours or
something of work over those those four
days and still get a lot of productivity
you know basically having the lines
almost running continuously that way
exactly so this is a strategy staggered
version of this idea where you take the
population divided into two groups or
three groups they say one group works
four weeks four days and then ten days
of lockdown then the other group kicks
in this idea was proposed by the
colleagues at bar-ilan University then
you get added benefit that during work
days there's less density if it's two
groups there's half the density and
that's transmission and you can keep
production lines working they almost
continuously like that and using this
staggered idea and apply it to think
about offices coming back I mean it
seems to me that as we've already seen
there's a lot of productivity that can
happen when you're at home so you could
picture on this idea people doing one
set of things during the four days when
they're say back at the office doing the
sort of you know exposure to each other
sparking off each other the sort of
discussions the brainstorming all that
good stuff while at home they're then
doing all the things that we've been
doing the last few weeks which is kind
of working working solo in it is that
how much have you thought about how that
whether it's possible effectively to
divide work into different types and
actually use a strategy like this to
maintain almost full or even better
productivity
increase for many sectors people work at
home very effectively and we've heard
from several industries that creativity
actually went up during a lockdown
people working at home so if you have a
schedule cyclic strictest you can
restrict the amount or you can plan the
work where you need to be to get there
in a very effective way with avoiding a
lot of time loss that occurs at work and
be more effective at home and more
effective at work and get high
productivity I should say that some
sectors really need to adjust like
hotels tourism dining several industries
this will require more thought and
adjusting but other industries are
almost built for ideas like this maybe
it's even something you can consider
after the epidemic because you can I
mean I read this and I I started
thinking about our own organization Ted
and how how in many ways you could argue
that could work really well I mean for
one thing there's this question about
extroverts and introverts some
introverts if they were honest might say
that this pandemic has been manna from
heaven for them they've they've found
work less stressful have they've been
able to focus and so forth with with
this sort of four days on four days off
type type strategy perhaps you can
imagine a work world that's optimized
for both introverts and extroverts
absolutely I mean I feel it also me and
my partner we have different
personalities we both teach in
universities and teaching through has
become the productive in certain ways
and so I agree completely and I think
here harnessing the creativity of people
at workplaces we're only the beginning
of what these kind of mixtures can offer
but for people who are on the front line
again how I mean it's you know if you're
if you're delivering goods and so forth
and you can't do that virtually is there
any thought about how a a for days on
and then isolation strategy how that off
time could be used to nonetheless
contribute to that person's work through
some form of training or is it more just
that people people would work very
intensely during four-day
and and maybe people still aren't quite
earning their full pay on this scenario
but it's better than complete lockdown
and it's better than going back to work
and seeing another surge that's right so
other than 30 level it's better than
opening up and seeing another surge
which will require a complete lockdown
for people like a hospital shift some
hospitals have adopted this kind of
program so you can protect shifts and
not avoid mixing and also traits a lot
of simplicity and clarity so you
understand when you're working and you
have some confidence because of this is
based on a scientific modelling about
the effectiveness of this plan it's also
equitable and defect in the sense that
everybody gets together to go to work
the only certain sector is transparent
and this is something that is best
implemented by an individual companies
or is it actually much better
implemented a city at a time or even a
nation at a time we think it can work at
nil so companies certain companies very
natural to adopt it or hospitals schools
etc can all it's also work in a level of
a town or a region and then we would
advise trying it out for something like
a month seeing whether cases rise in
that case you can don't turn down dial
down the number of work days or if cases
are declining quickly you can add work
days and therefore adapt to the climate
and the location where a person isn't
and so it's quite adaptable but by
aligning work schedules with schools for
example that suddenly allows parents to
go back to work on the days that their
kids are at school and you'd have to
you'd have to buy them
I mean is the best instantiation of this
that countries literally divided
households into sort of different a and
B categories or certain like that so
that they so that that kind of alignment
could happen exactly so you can align
different households group a and Group B
and then the children go to school the
parents go to work in a synchronised way
and the other group will it say they'll
turn it alternating week certain
people need to work all the time maybe
teachers in this they are like essential
workers they need to work throughout and
into account just like during the
lockdown situations the certain fraction
population still works throughout but
you should a region that does this
should be protected in sense because it
has replication number less than one so
important infections also can't spread
very very much and here is the
aforementioned David Biello David yes
hello everybody Yuri as you can imagine
there are a lot of questions from the
from the audience and we have a first
one kind of about those workers who have
been marked as essential can you comment
on how this would impact you know the
healthcare professionals and others who
may not have time or the flexibility to
quarantine in the way you suggest that's
great I want to say that there's
essential workers there's people with
low income they just can't adhere to
lockdown because they have to make a
living
the studies show that mobility if people
in low-income sectors is larger during
lockdown and also in developing
countries people just have to go out of
the house you can't enforce about them
so this for ten kind of strategy can
actually make lock lock down is easier
to bear for people who can still make a
living during those days and then or at
least you know make their own choices
about what fraction to work and what
fraction to stay in lockdown and some
countries can't get are less than one
even with lockdown because of this
adherence problem because informal
sectors that are we believe that a 410
cycle might make it easier to do
lockdown and maybe get our less a
reproduction every less than one that's
can identify billions of people in the
world I hope I answered your question I
think so and we have a another question
I believe if that can be queued up which
is any chance you can do the math and
quantify the increased risk of of this
410 cycle so in this paper we did all
the sensitivity analyses et cetera
and the question is it's comparing
increased risk comparing to what so we
kind of mean it's possible there will be
a second wave it's possible and in that
case its creator that the second wave in
another lockdown will be have worse
consequences and unhealth
and then a cycle of 410 and so and it's
really the question whether you're
comparing soup sure well thank you so
much for sharing this idea Yuri and
indeed David stay on but just just
before you go have have any governments
expressed interest in exploring this do
you see people considering actually
implementing this as as national policy
yes we in touch with several European
countries and countries in South America
and in Israel of course and Austria has
adopted a similar program for their
school system and which is a kind of a
five work school days every every two
weeks and several several companies and
hospitals etc and so we're very
interesting interested to see how this
will play out well I I love the basic
start point of starting by looking at
the enemy's weakness and it's you've got
this four-day period where some you know
it's not necessarily that dangerous
after an infection if you if you could
figure out a way to work then I assume
that testing would actually enhance this
idea as well a lot right to test people
before they you don't have to have
testing for this idea so that can apply
to regions without a lot of testing you
do have testing it could help you use
testing in a more effective way by
concentrating testing on people at the
end of their 10 doc down dates or just
as they're about to go to work and that
could make each test more impactful in
terms of reducing their application
reduction them in David instead of
having to test the whole population
every three or four days you it's just
once every two weeks that's a much more
in
goal sure
yeah well URI alone thank thank you so
much for spending this time